or better 9 is a Spanish science fiction
romantic drama the film follows Hellena
who believes that she has lived her
entire life isolated and alone on a
spaceship things change when a male
astronaut embarks on the station and we
follow the two characters as they fall
in love this foreign film has recently
saw release on Netflix and whilst on the
surface it seems fairly straightforward
there are several aspects towards the
end that may leave some viewers
scratching their head throughout this
video I will be discussing the film as
well as what I take the ending to
symbolize there will be heavy spoilers
so I highly suggest that you avoid this
video if you want to go into the film
fresh with that out the way I'm
definition and this is my ending
explanation of orbiter 9 throughout her
life Helena has had to deal with heavy
losses due to an urgent depletion of
oxygen aboard the ship
her parents were forced to commit
suicide so that she could survive when
an engineer named Alex bought her ship
for repairs she invites him to have
dinner with her following this she
approaches him in his cabin where he is
asleep and says that she has never been
kissed before they make love upon Alex
exiting the ship we discover that it is
in fact on earth helena is a guinea pig
part of an experiment in which humans
are monitored for their whole lives in
the interest of an eventual mission to
venture to the fictional planet of
Celeste this utopia offers humanity its
last chance of survival due to Earth's
poisoned oceans and diminishing
resources Alex was a pioneer of the
program to reach Celeste and to study
the human guinea pigs but he is now
rebelled returning to Helena due to the
connection he feels alex informs her
that the ship is only an observation
module in which all her movements and
biosigns are recorded daily this is of
course jarring for the character but
allows her to be freed in many ways Alex
smuggles Hellena to his apartment and
this allows her to experience the rain
and wind on a skin for the first time
something that she's never felt before
during her stay at the apartment Hellena
discovers that she is a clone furious
she tracks down her parents and lends
the truth about them
they are scientists unrelated to her
well aware of the experiment whilst
their father wishes to turn her in her
mother is unable to do so and frees her
Alexson Hellena are both now in danger
as the authorities begin to suspect
Alex's betrayal of the program they hunt
down in Kill Sylvia a psychologist whom
Alex's visited on a regular basis Sylvia
has provided Alex in Hellena with a safe
house and an apartment that she owns but
never visits the authorities continue to
hunt the pair Alex is allowed to get
away but Elena is captured in the final
scene Alex comes up with a way to be
with Helena again as she is pregnant the
scientists running the program are
unable to resist allowing Elena to birth
a child so that they can study it the
cycle is likely to continue
however we are offered a glimmer of hope
at the final scene of the film when
Elena's daughter steps out from orbiter
nine greeted by the scientists and
followed by a man she perhaps shows that
society as a whole has progressed this
could be taken to mirror the civil
rights movement and show that people as
a whole have grown to be better or it
could also mean that the scientists have
finally reached their goal and have far
means to travel to Celeste
[Music]
to me the film argues whether the needs
of the few
outweigh the needs of the many is it
worth taking away one person's life in
order to save millions whilst most will
struggle with this I personally believe
that though it may seem necessary on the
surface Elena's story showcases how we
must value one another and that all life
is precious finding out that she is in
fact a clone and isn't classified as a
real person still doesn't matter too
much to me and this technicality is
clearly being brought in by the
government to allow experimentation
there are clear Commons and slavery and
the way that African Americans were not
Dimas people during the slave trade so
that the owners could operate more
freely in their poor treatment of them
Holocaust similarities too can be found
by the fact that the Nazis used to
experiment on Jews after giving
propaganda to the citizens of Germany
making the race and religion seem less
than human
Alex falling in love with Elena clearly
indicates that she has a soul and should
be viewed as a person too and his
journey back to her is an empowering
example of love crossing all boundaries
of race gender and moral
well it's all Berta 9 was a little slow
at ports I still greatly enjoyed the
film and found within that there was a
clear message of love conquering all I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the film
so if you've seen it please comment
below and let me know if you'd like to
hear more of my ending explain videos
then please subscribe to my channel I
post videos like this regularly and
there will definitely be something on
the channel that you love you can check
out the recent one I did for a quiet
place and let me know if you agree or
disagree with my thoughts on the film
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this video and I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]